and the old method, which i also noticed from
my previous years in the
circle of shareholders,
was you somehow meet three times a
year, we then increased it to four times at some point,
then the
management presents an
annual report for three hours, so really
frontal teaching that stands  in the front you
sit here is the slice then at
some point a decision will be made but you
have zero
opportunity to take a critical look
afterwards or to follow up
because everything that was just a very
one-sided information channel the
documents you
received as a group of shareholders were
created by the management and there
logically it only contained what
you should see, so the
dirty corners
were actually gladly left out